a kindu riso o ma no a no
anat sud a nord sud
ai tempi per sorge un simulator mi
mettevo il camice perché erano youtuber
non pigro saggio il suo heather
anniversary edition perché hanno fatto
un miliardo di edizioni i secoli dei
secoli c'è ancora la mia ci sono per i
miei achievement aprire questo pacco
fantastico si può aprire si può non si
non si può aprire questo pacco per chi
non conoscesse surgeon simulator haga è
appunto un gioco dove si possono fare
dei trapianti non avreste mai detto e si
fanno con l'utilizzo della del braccio
che tu puoi muovere ma vi assicuro su
chi ha di più caro avete nella vita e
sperate che non si operi madame
manipolare questo braccio che vedete è
veramente un'impresa titanica proprio il
dottore oggi seguirà un trapianto di
cuore che è uno dei più semplici perché
dobbiamo trapiantare un solo organo
quindi io oggi vi spiego anche medicina
ancora ragazzi serve per pompare il
sangue è racchiuso dentro questa gabbia
inutile al pene che dio ci ha fatto
semplicemente per rendere le operazioni
chirurgiche incasinate del solito perché
se non ci fosse stata io a quest'ora
avrei già operato invece dello
scacciarla tutta però prima facciamo un
tutorial su come tenere un martello per
cortesia c'è veramente studiare medicina
impiega meno tempo che finire un
trapianto su sto gioco e non sto
scherzando allora la gabbia toracica e
andata non ci serve più martello andiamo
con l'estrazione dei polmoni tutto
questo gioco in realtà è un placement
all'orologio che ho al polso comprate
gli orologi led da amazon
helen è perfetto e che sono anche utili
per essere messi all'interno e possiamo
questo questo in teoria dovrebbe essere
un po un pokémon sto avendo una
difficoltà non indifferente
nell'estrarre i polmoni bene che poi non
li rimetterò dentro vintro solo il cuore
nuovo prove dopo i polmoni andiamo alle
estrarre quest'organo che non cosa mi
scusi mi spiega che se questo lei suo
dovrebbe saperlo come glielo lascio qui
si sa mai che abbia carenza d'affetto
andiamo a recidere lo stomaco per farlo
si fa così non esattamente
ok perfetto diamo anche a tagliare il
cuore direttamente se batte ancora vuol
dire che funziona
perfetto ce l'ho fatta sono riuscito a
togliere il cuore larga perfetto che poi
uno si chiede ma il cuore vecchio di un
paziente dove va a finire nei ristoranti
vegani perché i vegani mangiano i cuori
di chi non è vegano per ripicca questa
ecco forse questo è un po più pokémon di
colori prima però io vorrei vedere dov'è
il cuore nuovo eccolo qui il nuovo di
pacca amazon prime questo qua va
posizionato in un modo molto preciso che
bene ragazzi quattro minuti e 47 tutto
dire perché ci ho messo una vita e mezza
per fare sto per azione ai tempi quindi
la mia bravura nei confronti della
chirurgia moderna è rimasta sono stato
capace di farlo subito in tutto questo
l'orologio dentro il paziente è rimasto
e vabbè omaggio ieri fa sarà la prossima
operazione che quella di reni ecco i
reni e un po più un casino perché sono
due
mi scusi lei lei e il paziente di prima
la può smettere di ammalarsi ogni tre
secondi può condurre una vita sana per
cortesia che cosa fa di così strano
nella sua vita da farsi venire così
tanti malori
guardo i video di favi j procediamo per
il trapianto di reni signori vanno
utilizzati degli attrezzi delicati
perché il trapianto di reni e molto
molto delicato alla partenza dovrebbe
essere tra le più semplici
non mi ricordo assolutamente quali erano
i punti da tagliare ma va bene paziente
che mischia
ok ho tagliato tutto va bene siringa la
siringa questa roba verdastra non lo so
sinceramente le cose però ferma
l'emorragia quindi è utile se mi pongo
con questa roba è un casino perfetto
mamma mia che brutta roma veramente noi
abbiamo questa roba nel corpo
mamma mia che brutta ho lavato raga
alien stati impiccati col tuo stesso
intestino bene ma c'è anche il laser mi
chiamerebbero dimenticato forse nel
massimo in questo momento provo vero non
so neanche io bene cosa decidere in
questo momento però ci sto morendo sto
morendo il paziente la siringa mi dia
una mano ma non così
sono trovato porca vacca stop stop stop
si è fermato ok fosse il laser non è
stata l'idea migliore però sono rimasti
ancora 400 millilitri di sangue siamo
nella cacca p totale ragazzi sono pure
drogato ma qualcosa mi dice che la
falliamo questa operazione potremmo
avere per cortesia un taglierino che
grazie a queste cose non le usiamo solo
per gli emo faccia ce la fai a preoc
perfetto adesso dovrei riuscito a
tagliare anche i reni se dio vuole due
perfetto a siringa frate che stai
perdendo sangue
raga ho perso la siringa sta morendo il
paziente veloce veloce a sostituire i
reni veloce ai 120 secondi neanche
perché non riesco a prendere le cose
quanti problema donna
vuoi vedere se se stasera ti fai le
pippe riesce a prenderti veneti
giocatolo taglio maraga non è possibile
dove la siringa definita si deve niente
né morto
porca vacca e uno s'impegna studia
medicina 10 anni e poi risultati sono
questi
marcava h vaffan cuore ma poi per
mettere a posto le ossa cosa usiamo il
l'attacco mi sa che li sto facendo un
sacco male da mila siringa di nuovo
grazie
i tagli così decidiamo
perché allora 1 via da amplifon gesù
perfetto treni nuovi per favore dove
sono qua uno lo metto ma dove lo metto
questo destra o sinistra perché non c'è
scritto non è come per le cuffiette che
c'è scritto destra sicura non troviamo a
destra o va bene andiamo lì di cervello
c'è quello di occhi e quello di denti
dove andiamo di cervello rai a lui
insomma è il mio mestiere devo farlo il
trapianto di cervello tipo come cucinare
l'uovo alla coque aprite così
delicatezza frate delicatezza delicate
anche fatto comunque ragazzi nel
trapianto di cervello il paziente in
questione e pietro perché chi altro puoi
fare un trapianto cervelliamo un motivo
a pietro di esistere perché con quello
che adesso che si ritrovano nel torino
brutto è brutto essere stupidi
tranquillo amico mio ci penso io a
renderti intelligente devo fermarti
l'emorragia quindi prendi st siringhe
non ti lamentare grazie ok aiuto come
faccio ho avuto un gems che togliere il
cervello è un casino ma noi ci proviamo
3 2 1 all è perfetto pietro ti ho
liberato da del tuo più grande peso
vediamo che cosa possiamo inserire
all'interno per rendere pietro più
intelligente di prima
ok tuttavia adesso dovesse essere molto
meglio di prima perché hai lasciato il
cervello nell'acqua gassata ma lo vuoi
spiegare tac no vabbè veloce lasciando
al volo che culo si castrato è sempre
devo questo è un casino e tieni a posto
ci ho preso anche c non è andata neanche
troppo male va bene ragazze abbiamo
fatto cuore e reni cervello e direi che
siamo a posto manca solo quello di denti
non lo faccio perché non mi piace però
quello gli occhi come ultimo trapianto
di oggi direi che coloro gli occhi può
bastare quello di occhi è un po un
casino perché la prima cosa da fare
ragazzi a rompere la mascherina che gli
ho messo li guardi mi guardi di qua
a posto la seconda cosa da fare per il
trapianto di occhi rai questo è un po
difficile quindi intenzione non guardate
se siete deboli di cuore con quanta
delicatezza sto facendo
questa cosa è ok perfetto un altro ce
n'è un altro grazie meno male che oggi
non badiamo a spese se in atto con gli
occhi marroni ma è sempre desiderato
avere gli occhi azzurri vieni da fa vj
mamma mia che brutta cosa ho fatto
ok perfetto bene allora un occhio e
quasi a quasi andato l'altro sta sta
l'altro un casino adesso tagliarli in
teoria dovrebbe essere uno scherzo
perché basta tagliare ciocche perfetto
ancora l'altro ok
secondo me se non trovarti adesso non
adesso
per cortesia madonna madonna a è a posto
emorragia fermato dove l'altro siringa
dove l'altra siringa sono drogato non
posso mettere gli occhi la droga va bene
proviamoci raga occhi mentre sono
drogato mai così è un set di occhi
azzurri questo è zio devi ringraziarmi e
basta come si inserisce un occhio nei la
cavità orbitale no beh meno male che ho
più tentativi e fatto è difficilissimo
centro giuro non riescono anche come
dove
perfetto il primo è andato l'altro è uno
e uno smile ma spero ti vada bene lo
stesso se come rimorchi che piacere
l'altro era di amazon prime questo l'ho
preso usuali express direttamente dalla
cina perfetto mette ansia farsi cosa
sono basta ragazzi miei spero vi sia
piaciuto ho fatto quattro trapianti in
un video solo ai tempi ne facevo
facciamo un trapianto un video intero
quindi ragazzi fare un salto indietro e
stato bello anche perché mi ricordo ai
vecchi tempi di mi divertivo un sacco
spero vi siate divertiti comunque io ho
fatto del mio meglio se mai avesse
bisogno di cambiare il colore degli
occhi 5 euro per avere sia piaciuta
ragazzi cosi subito ci sono e mi piace
anche a vari social che mi notò
trascrizione solo dove si scateni ci
vediamo al prossimo visto dai ragazzi mi
fa una cortesia per favore se mi
controlla l'ora quando sono le otto e
mezzo
me lo dica che devo sfornare il pollo
grazie
[Musica]